je vais compter à partir de de l'embout
à chaque fois sur lit sur qui le chiffre
va tomber sera c'est bon ça sera pas
d'accord est-ce que vous êtes prêts
c'est parti 1 2 3 allez donc 4 7 et 2 9
10 14 17 20 22 25 28 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21
26 27 28 tu es sauvé Géraldine
[Applaudissements]
6 7 9 13
15 17 20 21 21
[Musique]
elle sait que c'est bon il y aura eu un
autre
comme ça
tu vois ce que je subis
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 21
attention c'est reparti
top 3 0 5 5 et de 7 à 7 et de 9 9 et 4
13 et 4 17 et 0 17 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10
non 17 les mecs gardez bien vos chiffres
1 2
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 non non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention c'est reparti 1 2 3 3 0 6 si
c'est de 8 8 et 3 11 11
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 c'est souris
[Applaudissements]
faire toute la première partie
d'émission avec une tête d'or
je suis encore dedans attention 3 2 1
5 et 2 7 7 8 et 4 12 et 5 17 et 2 19 1 2
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 mais là
je suis encore dedans attention
3 2 1 top 5 et 1 6 6 4 10 10 15 16 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
[Applaudissements]
je vais demander maintenant aux quatre
loosers de se mettre de ce côté
Géraldine veut passer là qui est
qualifié non non
merci tu te mets à côté de Guillaume
merci c'est très important ce sera entre
ces quatre qui va avoir une tête de rat
je la mets donc à côté de vous
[Rires]
une tête de rat pendant la première
partie de l'émission On va démarrer
maintenant par Guillaume d'accord
c'est reparti 3 2 1 top 2 4 et 4,8 et 4
12 je ne suis plus dedans
un deux trois quatre cinq six sept huit
neuf dix onze
j'ai maintenant j'ai maintenant une
proposition à vous faire
celui qui accepte de ne pas être payé
aujourd'hui et éliminer d'office
[Rires]
[Musique]
avec le nom à côté celui qui trouve
celui qui trouve s'il vous plaît celui
qui trouve qui va porter la tête de rat
qui a la bonne réponse non non instant
gagnera un rat c'est un
ça vaut le coup attention
vous avez mis trop de temps on va
refaire vous avez mis trop de temps il
faut aller plus vite il faut vraiment
sortir en même temps parce que vous
pouvez faire des calculs à partir de
maintenant 3 2 1 top 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
[Applaudissements]
les chéris ça va être entre vous deux
maintenant
attention 3 2 1 top 1 2 3 c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
merci seul seul une personne ici peut la
sauver quelqu'un qui dit je la prendrais
à sa place à la tête de rat je la
prendrai à sa place la tête de
vomi
c'est Kelly qui portera la tête
si vous nous rejoignez quel est une tête
de rat
voilà donc c'est le plus beau rat du
monde
on a tous des têtes de cul
Valérie
c'est sur Kelly
là c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est quoi
alors que tout le monde voulait que ça
tombe sur Gilles
est-ce que vous venez pas de créer un
format en direct qui aura la tête de rat
non mais je vous jure que c'est vrai
c'est une émission demain on fera un
nouveau jeu comme ça avec un nouveau
gage chaque jour on fera le jeu du gage
à
10h50 avec les chiffres comme ça c'est
incroyable une tension je vous dis que
c'est vrai c'est incroyable demain tu
seras qui aura la tête dans le cul
[Applaudissements]